- Mark's eyes rolled
into the back of his head.
And he starts to spit out
Mountain Dew and Cheeto dust.
He looks like a dragon,
and he starts swinging
the joystick
in front of his body
like a martial arts weapon,
and for the first time I saw
fear in my big brother's eyes.
He was like, "Hey, dude,
take it easy,"
and he's like--
[high-pitched voice] "Hiyah!"
- The baby's coming!
It's coming!
[dark electronic music]
[grunting]
[yells]
♪
[screams]
Ooh.
Hello.
♪
[groaning]
[screaming]
♪
[cheers and applause]
- He's got his own podcast
called "Good Times
with Steve Simeone."
It's amazing.
Please give it up
for Mr. Steve Simeone,
everybody.
[cheers and applause]
- So yeah, I have a story
about my family.
I think family's
a pretty incredible thing
because it teaches you
unconditional love.
Like, seriously, if you think
back to your childhood,
and if you treated
a stranger now
as poorly as you treated
your brothers, sisters,
and cousins,
you'd be in jail right now.
That's the truth.
In my house, a felony
was committed every day.
Every day,
a felony was committed.
Blackmail, extortion,
assault, larceny,
arson more than once,
attempted murder.
It happened all the time,
because my big brother
was the worst offender.
He was a dick, okay?
And I remember
this one year for Christmas
we all got excited,
because we had to come together
and ask Santa for a family gift,
like, a big gift,
and I was like, "Oh, what are we
gonna get? Can we get a monkey?"
Right, like, I didn't know.
Right?
And my big brother was like,
"We're gonna get an Atari."
I'm like, "I don't even know
what that is."
He was like,
"We're gonna ask for an Atari."
So, we got an Atari
that year for Christmas,
and if you're not old enough
to remember what an Atari is,
it was the first
video game system for the house.
Dude, right, I--so many kids,
they're like, "What do you mean?
You couldn't play
on your phone?"
No, dude, back in the day
you needed a quarter
to play video games,
and you'd run out,
so you'd have to go
through your house
like the goddamn Goonies
looking for pirate treasure
to find another quarter.
I'm going, like, "Where did Dad
sit? Check the couch there."
We're going through my mom's
old jackets.
[imitates hawk]
"We got quarters!"
So you'd ride your bike
to a video game thing
or maybe get a ride
to the mall,
and then you could be
at the arcade,
but then, you could be
in the middle of a game,
and three teenagers show up
in Black Sabbath t-shirts,
and you're like,
"Forget it,
"I'm not getting stabbed
over Q*bert.
The game's yours."
[cheers and applause]
So--so this Atari
was supposed to bring joy
into our house,
but it didn't,
'cause my big brother
ruined it.
And it wasn't the fact
that he would just beat us
in the video games.
He would sing songs to us
as he was beating us
in the games.
Like, he'd be like--
♪ You did your best
♪ But I guess your best
wasn't good enough ♪
I'm like,
"Shut up, dude!"
He's like, "Hey, relax,
it's just a game."
So we're still playing,
and then he kept quiet.
And then right before the game
was over,
he'd go,
"Do you hear that?"
And I'd go, "Hear what?"
He goes, "Shh, shh, shh!
"Do you hear that?"
I go, "What?"
He goes, "I think it's Queen
warming up in the background."
♪ No time for losing
'cause I am the champion ♪
Now I'm shaking like McFly
at end of "Back to the Future."
I'm like,
"You fat son of a bitch!
It's on!"
And I hit him,
but that's what he wanted,
he wanted me to hit him,
because he outweighed me
by 100 pounds,
and then he'd just start
to choke-slam me
like André the Giant
and drop a big Hulk Hogan leg
and then pin me for a five count
like King Kong Bundy,
and then my dad would be like,
"Son of a bitch!
I'll unplug
the goddamn game!"
Now my dad's running downstairs,
he's breaking up the fight.
He's like, "Chris,
go to your room!"
And Chris is like,
"Steve started it."
And he was like, "Well, then
you're going to your room too!"
How the hell is that fair?
That's not fair.
It's not.
So my little brother knew
he could never beat up
my big brother.
So he decided to get him
where it counted.
Video game championship
of the house.
Yes.
My little brother became
like the Rudy of video games.
He would wake up
at 5:00 in the morning
when nobody was awake
just to practice.
He knew where my mom hid
all the junk food,
so he would steal,
like, a 2-liter bottle
of Mountain Dew.
Bro, before there was Red Bull
or 5-Hour Energy,
there was mother-effing
Mountain Dew.
[cheering]
Right?
Twice the caffeine,
twice the sugar.
He's drinking it warm
straight out of the 2-liter.
He looked like a rapper
drinking a 40 of St. Ides
back in the '90s.
He'd be like "Mountain Dew!"
And then his little heart
would start getting jacked,
and he's ripping open cheese
curls at 6:00 in the morning,
shoving Cheetos
in his mouth,
and that orange
and cheese curl dust
is floating
through the living room
like cocaine
in "The Departed."
Do you remember
when Nicholson had these, like--
[high-pitched voice]
"Cheese curls! Cheese curls!"
And then he would get excited
and backwash it
into the Mountain Dew--
disgusting.
'Cause it looked like
a bottle of Goldschlager
with, like, just pieces of stuff
floating in there
like one of those
snow globes.
So Mark, he got really good
at video games, right?
But then some of the kids
didn't believe him,
that he got that good
at video games.
They're like, "Why are you lying
to make friends?"
He's like,
"I didn't. I did it."
So this is how smart
my little brother was.
He's like,
"I'm gonna need evidence."
So he bought
a Polaroid camera
to take pictures
of the TV set
to prove that he beat games
and stuff.
And then, I remember
this kid Jason was like,
"You--we don't believe you."
He's like, "Oh, really?
I wish I had something
to show you."
Boom. Right?
And everybody's like,
"Oh, that's awesome!"
And then Jason was like,
"Yeah?
Well, how do we know
you did it?"
And the next picture is,
like, my little brother
hugging the TV like--
[high-pitched voice]
"I knocked out Mike Tyson,
bitch." Right?
So, Mark got good
at games.
My big brother doesn't
know this, right?
Couple years had gone by.
I remember this day vividly.
Okay.
My big brother's
on the game console,
he's down there,
he's warming up.
He doesn't know
Mark's gotten this good.
We are confident.
I mean,
we come down the steps
like Ric Flair
in The Four Horsemen confident.
Like, my little brother's
like, "Whoo!
"You might not like it,
but one day,
you'll learn to love it,
fat boy!"
Let's rock."
Mark immediately starts
lighting him up
and he's like,
"It's awfully quiet over there,
you must be losing.
Bawk, bawk." Right?
And Chris is like, "Shut up."
And Mark's like, "Okay. Relax.
"It's just a game.
Hey, Chris, do you hear that?"
And Chris goes, "Hear what?"
He goes, "I think it's Queen
warming up in the background."
♪ No time for losing
♪ 'Cause I am
the new champion! ♪
"Steve, take a picture
of his fat face when I win."
So I'm like, "Dude,
where's your camera?"
And he's like, "Oh, my God!
I left it upstairs."
I'm like, "What?"
He goes, "It's next to
the Fruity Pebbles!"
So as I'm running up the steps
and Mark's not looking,
Chris unplugged
his joystick.
[crowd murmurs]
Oh!
Oh, my God, it gets
so much worse.
So much worse.
So I'm coming down the steps
and I just see Mark going,
"I can't move my man.
"I can't move my man!
Hit pause! Hit pause!"
And Chris is going, "What?
I can't hear you.
Queen's playing too loud."
He's like,
"This doesn't count!"
Chris wins the game.
Immediately,
Mark starts to cry.
"I hate you." And when Mark
pushes Chris away,
he sees that
that cord was unplugged.
Oh, my effing goodness.
I didn't think this could happen
in real life.
Mark's eyes rolled
into the back of his head,
and he starts to spit out
Mountain Dew and Cheeto dust.
He looks like a dragon.
And he starts swinging
the joystick
in front of his body
like a martial arts weapon.
And for the first time, I saw
fear in my big brother's eyes.
He was like, "Hey dude.
Take it easy."
And he was like,
"I hate you!"
Now it's over his head
like Indiana Jones.
It sounds like a Blackhawk's
landing in our family room.
And he's just going,
"Die, bitch, die!"
And he starts to smash
my big brother in the face.
I'm like,
"What should I do?"
And Mark, he's like,
"Help me!"
So we double-teamed on him,
dropping those
mother-effing bees on him.
We're giving him
a ghetto boy's beat down.
I don't know if it's doing
any damage, but it feels great.
I'm like, "Take that,
fat boy, take that."
Marky starts to take
the cord,
and he's wrapping it
around Chris' throat.
He's making noises like
Luca Brasi in "The Godfather."
Like--[groaning]
I'm like,
"You're gonna kill him!"
"I want to kill him!"
So as Mark's leaning in
on the choke,
I see Chris's legs
start to shake,
and his chubby fingers
going back and forth like this.
Like--
[breathing heavily]
Like Hulk Hogan in The Sleeper,
and he just throws Mark.
[whooshes]
Mark flies.
And he gets up and he's like--
[breathing heavily]
And I'm like, "Hey man.
I'm glad you won."
And he goes, "Oh, yeah?
I'm glad I did this."
And he went...boom.
Right in my face.
Now, look, there's a code
to brother wars.
It's passed down
from generation to generation.
No punching to the face.
Everything else is
on the books.
You could throw a ninja star
at your brother,
launch a bottle rocket
at him,
put a stick in his bike
and watch him flip over.
All that's cool.
But no kicking to the balls
and no punching to the face.
So he drops me,
and I'm pissed.
I get up and I'm like,
"Oh, ho, ho, eff this.
I'm getting Mom!"
And I take off.
He's like,
"Where are you going?"
I'm like,
"I'm getting Mom!
You're going to jail, bitch!
You're going to jail!"
And Mark is like,
"We're pressing charges!
We're pressing charges!"
Now, Chris is real calm, and
he's like, "Where you going?"
I'm like, "I'm getting Mom!
You're going to jail, bitch!"
And he just looks at me,
he goes,
"You mean, uh, my mom, right?"
And I went...
"Get--I'm getting Mom."
He's like,
"The woman you live with?
"That's my mom.
Nobody ever told you
that you were adopted?"
And Marky goes,
"That's not true."
"Is it not true?
Did I punch you in the face?
"No, 'cause you're
my real brother.
I punched Steve in the face
'cause he's a stranger."
I was like,
"Well, I'm--
I'm still gonna tell."
He's like, "Go ahead.
"Tell my mom that her real son
had to punch you in the face.
"See what happens.
She'll make you pack up
your stuff and leave."
I was like...
[laughter]
"I don't have
anywhere else to go."
So he's like, "Well...
"I guess I won't tell.
"So if you don't tell,
you can just come down here
and pretend this didn't happen."
I was like,
"Thanks, man."
He's an evil genius.
He punches me in the face
and I'm thanking him for it.
So I didn't--I didn't have
an ending to that story,
'cause that, like, happened.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, it just--
I was just like, "Yeah,
my big brother was a jerk
and had me convinced
for a couple years
that I was adopted.
Like, it happened
all the time.
We would always fight,
we would always say
the meanest stuff possible.
So then I was like, "Yeah,
if I talk about this onstage,
people can relate to it,
you know?"
That's it, like, big brother--
brothers can be mean
and you love each other
through it and that's it.
Now we're awesome friends.
So, one night after a show,
this guy came up to me,
and he was like,
"You know what, dude?
"My big brother,
same thing.
He used to tell me I was adopted
all the time."
He--and I was like,
"Yeah, they're jerks, right?"
And he was like,
"Well, the messed up thing is,
years later I found out
I really was adopted.
Yeah, and here's the thing
though, he wasn't the only--
People started to come up to me
and they were like--
Like, they had this uneasiness
about being adopted.
I'm like, "Oh, my God,
this is not what I want to do."
I want to put more love
into the world
and remind people
that family's awesome
and it's the little things
and pizza night and stuff.
You know?
And then the other thing is,
like, so I always thought
I wanted to adopt kids
at some point,
maybe 'cause, in hindsight,
my brother told me
I was adopted
for years.
But, right, like I think
what a privilege it would be,
'cause getting back to that
whole unconditional love thing.
Like, how amazing that would be
to, like, one day hear my kids
getting into a fight downstairs
and one kid's like,
"You know you were adopted?"
And he's like, "Yeah,
that's right, bitch,
"'cause Mom and Dad
wanted me.
"They walked into a room
and picked me out.
"You were an accident.
"You just showed up
and they were like,
'How we gonna feed this one?'"
Good night
and God bless you.
Take care.
[dark electronic music]
♪